The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Please note that this
is a clicker competition,
perhaps the last of the year,
before you put in your vote
for this particular
clicker question.
And the defending champs are
recitation three, and I
believe that no recitation
has won more than once.
Is that true?
Is there a recitation that
has two victories?
So, this might be your last
chance if your recitation has
not won, or if you want to be
decisive victors in the
clicker competition to have a
repeat victory, this is your
chance -- no pressure.
But go ahead and put in
your clicker response.
OK, let's just take 10 more
seconds to click in.
OK, the answer here is b, and
the trick was to recognize
which is the equation for first
order half life, and
which is the equation for
second order half life.
Most people got this right.
And we picked this clicker
question to demonstrate a
point that will, for the final
exam, which is that you will
have an equation sheet
of all the equations.
There'll be a few you have to
memorize, we'll let you know
what they are, but that's
a lot of equations.
So, so far on each hour exam,
you've had an equation sheet
that's been related to that
particular material.
On the final, you of an equation
sheet that has the
equations from exam 1, exam 2,
exam 3, and also the fourth
exam material.
And so, it doesn't say on them,
oh, first order half
life equation, colon, and then
the equation, it just has all
of the equations.
So one thing that you have to do
is recognize which equation
can be applied where.
And this is something that
people, occasionally that's
part of knowing the
material is to
know/recognize the equations.
You don't have to memorize them,
but you do have to be
able to recognize them and
know when to apply them.
So that's something you should
be thinking about as you're
reviewing the material
for the exam.
And we're just going to at jump
right in and talk about
reaction mechanisms. So this is
the last type of question
that's on problem-set 10.
So, when you're investigating
reaction mechanisms, you often
will have an experimentally
determined rate law, and then
you want to try to come up
with a mechanism that's
consistent with that rate law.
So, for this particular
reaction, we have 2 n o plus o
2 going to 2 n o 2 gas.
And experimental rate laws
determined there was a rate
constant called k obs, for k
observed, the observed rate
constant that was calculated.
And we know that it's the order
of the reactions here.
Overall, what is the overall
order at this
particular rate law?
Three.
So we have second order in n
o and first order in o 2.
So if it's overall order of
three, is it likely to occur
in one step?
No.
What would it be called if it
did occur in one step -- if
three things came together
at the same
time to form a product?
Yeah, thermonuclear.
And we learned last time
that thermonuclear
reactions are rare.
So it's unlikely that those
three things, the two n o's
and the one o 2 are going to
come together at the same time
to form product, so
it probably has
more than one step.
So, on the board here and on
your notes, we have a two-step
proposed mechanism, and let's
talk about these two steps and
come up with a rate law that's
consistent with this
mechanism, and then see if
that agrees with the
experimental rate law
that was determined.
So, in the first step of this
reaction, we have 2 n o's
coming together.
There's a little rate constant,
k 1, above the first
arrow, and for the reverse
direction, we have k minus 1,
so this is written as a
reversible reaction, and it's
forming an intermediate
n 2 o 2.
In the second step, we have the
o 2 coming in, reacting
with that intermediate with a
rate constant, k 2, and it's
forming two molecules
of n o 2.
So now we can write the
rates for each of
these individual steps.
We can write the rate for the
foward reaction here, and so
that's going to be
equal to k 1.
And we have n o, two n
o's, so n o squared.
And again, this is a step or an
elementary reaction so we
can write the reaction
exactly as it occurs.
We can write a rate law for
that step using the
stiochiometry of the reaction.
For an overall reaction, you
can't do that, it has to be
experimentally determined.
But for an elementary reaction
or a step in a mechanism, you
can do that.
So we write it exactly
as it occurs.
So, what would be the order of
this particular reaction as
written here?
Two.
And what about molecularity?
It would be bimolecular.
So we're just getting you used
to some of these terms.
All right, so then for the
reverse direction, the rate of
the reverse direction would be
equal to what rate constant?
k minus 1.
Times what?
Yeah, n 2 o 2.
So what's the order here?
One.
And what's this called?
Yeah, so that's called
unimolecular.
All right, what about step 2?
What would be the rate
here, and that
is a clicker question.
OK, just 10 more seconds.
Yup, so we write it exactly as
written, so we have a k 2
times the concentration
of o 2 times the
concentration of n 2 o 2.
All right, so what is the
overall order here?
Two.
And again, that would
be the bimolecular.
All right, so we have our two
steps, and we've written rates
for all of those particular
steps.
Now we're interested in writing
the rate of the
overall reaction that
forms n o 2.
So, let's think about what the
rate of n o 2 formation is.
So, in the last step, we're
forming n o 2, and we can just
use that last step to
write this out.
We're forming two molecules
of n o 2.
So we're going to put a 2 in
there, because the rate at
which the concentration of this
will increase twice as
much as will decrease
this amount.
And the book is somewhat
inconsistent in its use of 2's
in these equations.
If you're forming two molecules
in your last step,
there should be a 2, but 2 is
not always in the answer key.
So what I've done in the past
is if you put a 2 and there
should be a 2, great, but if you
don't put it, that's OK,
too, so I have not taken off for
this because the book is
not been completely consistent
in its use of that.
But, if you see a two, and 2
things are being formed, you
know where that comes from.
So, 2 times k 2, that's the
rate constant of that last
step, and that we're talking
about the concentration of o 2
and the concentration
of n 2 o 2.
So we're writing out just that
last out there with the 2,
because two molecules of
n o 2 are being formed.
But we're not done with this, we
can't use this, because it
has an intermediate
term in there.
And if we're going to write the
rate of a reaction, the
rate of product formation, we
can't have any intermediates
in our equation.
We need to solve it in terms
of products and reactants.
So, we need to solve
for n 2 o 2.
So we need to solve for the
concentration of n 2 o 2, and
substitute that into
our equation.
So we need to solve
for it in terms of
products and reactants.
So, we need to think about how
this intermediate is formed,
and we need to think about
how the intermediate is
decomposed, and we need to
think about how this
intermediate is consumed.
So, the net formation of n 2 o
2 is going to be equal to the
rate at which it's formed.
So the rate at which
it's formed.
What step is it formed in, the
intermediate formed in?
It's in step one in the forward
direction, so the rate
at which its formed is k
1 times n o squared.
So that's the forward rate
of the first step.
Then we need to think about
the rate at which its
decomposed.
What step does the intermediate
decompose in?
Right, the reverse of
the first step.
So we're going to put a minus
sign here, and k minus 1 times
the concentration of
the intermediate.
And then we also want to
think about the rate
at which it's consumed.
And it's consumed in the second
step, so that's k 2
times the concentration of the
intermediate times the
concentration of o 2.
So that's the net formation.
And now we can use something
called the steady state
approximation, and the steady
state approximation is used in
all sorts of kinetics, including
enzyme kinetics, and
it can be phrased two different
ways, which are
equivalent.
You can say that the steady
state approximation is that
the net formation of the
intermediate equals zero --
i.e. this is the net formation
of the intermediate, so this
entire equation equals zero.
Another way to say it is that
the rate of formation of the
intermediate equals
the rate of decay.
So that's saying the same thing,
that this term is going
to be equal to those
two terms. That's
saying the same thing.
So, if we can set this whole
equation equal to zero, then
we can solve for the
concentrations of the
intermediates in terms of the
rate constants and the
concentrations of the reactants
and the products,
which is what we need to do.
So, let's do that.
So we can rearrange this
expression now that we have
set equal to zero, and so we can
bring n 2 o 2 over to one
side, so we have our
intermediate on one side.
And then we are going to have k
minus 1, and our little k 2
times the concentration
of o 2.
And so, that is the rate in
which the intermediate is
decomposed and consumed, and
that's going to be equal to
the rate at which it's formed,
which is another way of
expressing the steady
state approximation.
So we've just moved the
decomposed and consumed to one
side, and we have the rate at
which it's formed on the other
side, and now we can easily
solve for the concentration of
the n 2 o 2, so we're going
to do that over here.
So that's now going to be equal
to our k 1 times n o
squared over k minus 1
plus k 2 times the
concentration of o 2.
So now we've just solved for n
2 o 2, our intermediate, in
terms of our rate constants and
in terms of our reactants.
So that's good.
Now we need to take this and
substitute it back into here.
And if we substitute it back
into here, let's do that over
here, so now we'll have
k, 2 times k 2, we'll
also have a k 1 term.
We're going to have, we
have n o squared.
We also have an o 2 term from
over here, and this is all
going to be over k minus
1 plus k 2 times our
concentration of o 2.
So we've just substituted that
term in here, and now we have
a new expression for the rate of
our product formation, and
that's lovely.
Except that it doesn't agree
with the experiment.
So we have a problem.
In the experiment, there's n o
squared and o 2, but there is
no o 2 in the bottom, so
something is going on.
So that means that our reaction
as written, which
didn't have any fast steps or
any slow steps is inconsistent
if you write a mechanism for
this, if you write a rate law
for this, it's inconsistent
with the experiment.
So we need to do more to
our proposed mechanism.
We need to add fast steps and
slow steps until we can write
a mechanism that agrees
with the experiment.
And so, if we want to do this,
we're going to assume, now we
can try that the first
step is fast and the
second step is slow.
So let's talk about this slow
step and what happens if you
have a slow step.
So I'm going to introduce this
term of rate determining step.
So the slowest step in an
elementary reaction is going
to determine the overall rate.
If it's slow compared
to the other steps.
And so, the overall rate, it
can't be any faster than that
slow step, and that slow step
is going to govern how fast
the overall reaction is.
All right, so let me give
you an example of this.
I know they're you're all
very anxious to complete
problem-set 10, the last
problem-set that will be
graded in this course.
And you know, because I told you
at the beginning of class,
that after today's lecture, you
will know all the material
that will allow you to complete
that problem-set.
So some of you are going to get
really antsy at the end of
class thinking OK, I can go
and do that problem-set.
So, you're going to be ready,
you may have already started
packing up your backpack as the
class is winding down, you
see we're getting close to the
end of the handouts saying,
all right, I've got to get out
of here, I've got to get to
the library and finish the
rest of problem-set 10.
All right, so let's say it takes
you five seconds to pack
up and be out the door.
Or maybe there's some people
coming in, OK, maybe ten
seconds to get out the door.
Then you're running down toward
the library and you're
moving pretty fast, you're
jumping over people that are
stopping and talking to their
friends, you're moving very
quickly, you might slide down
the banisters to get to the
first floor, and you get
to the library, but
you were too slow.
Even though you did it really
fast, all the tables are busy,
everyone else is completing
problem-set 10.
So you go up and down, you're
looking for a table, there's
no tables, they're all busy,
everyone has their chemistry
textbooks out and
they're going.
All right.
So, then you have to leave the
library, you go to building 2,
that's close by, they're
classrooms, they're not in
use, the first couple
you check there's
recitations going on.
Finally you find the
one that's empty.
When you find it that's empty,
your backpack is off, your
books are out, your
calculator's
out and you're going.
Right, maybe another
ten seconds.
But it took you about
20 minutes to
find that free table.
So, maybe ten seconds to get
out of this classroom, ten
seconds to get your books out of
your backpack, but then 20
minutes overall to find
that free table.
So that's the rate determining
step, that 20 minutes to find
that table is going
to control the
overall rate of the reaction.
And so, many of you have
probably experienced rate
determining steps in your life,
some of you may have
friends that are always your
rate determining step, and so
you know about this.
You know about this.
And so rate determining steps
allow us to come up with
different kinds of mechanisms
and simplify different
expressions.
All right, so let's look at what
this does for us here.
If we make assumptions now about
a step being fast and a
step being slow.
All right, so we're going to be
able to -- this expression
here, we're going to be
able to simplify.
All right, so we're going to ask
the question then, here,
we're assuming that we're going
to say, all right, let's
just say the first step
is fast and the
second step is slow.
We're going to see whether that
gives us an answer that's
consistent with the
experimentally
determined rate law.
So here, if we say this is
fast and this is slow,
basically we're asking the
question, is the decomposition
of the intermediate or it's
consumption faster?
So as we wrote this, then, we're
saying decomposition is
fast. The first step is fast
and reversible, so the
decomposition is fast. The
second step is slow, the
consumption of that intermediate
is slow.
So that allows us to
change our rate.
So, what we're then saying in
terms of the here's the words,
here's sort of the equations,
we're saying that this term
here, this k minus 1 times the
intermediate term, is a lot
bigger, because this is
faster than this.
This is slow, the rate of
consumption is slow.
So k minus 1 is going to
be a bigger number
than k 2 times o 2.
So, if we say that, if we say
this is fast, that's a big
number, this is a fast step,
k 2 is a small number, it's
slow, if this is a lot smaller
than k minus 1, and these are
both appearing in the bottom
of the equation here, that
allows you to get rid
of this term.
So if you have something really
big and something
pretty small, on the bottom of
this equation, the really
small thing is kind
of insignificant.
And so we can get rid
of that here.
So we can get rid
of this term.
So that allows us to simplify
this expression.
Now we have k 1 times n o
squared over k minus 1.
We can also rearrange that and
bring our concentration terms
on one side, so we have our
intermediate over our n o
squared and have that now is
going to be equal to k 1
over k minus 1.
What is little rate constant
k 1 over rate
constant k minus 1?
Big k, right.
So that's another way of
saying the equilibrium
expression.
So it's the equilibrium constant
for the first step is
equal to k 1 over k minus 1.
So basically what we're saying
then, if we have the first
step being fast and reversible,
and the second
step being slow, we're saying
that the first step is really
an equilibrium.
So what allows us to say that?
Well, if you have a fast
reversible step followed by a
slow step, that means that not
much of your intermediate is
being siphoned off by the second
step, allowing you to
reach equilibrium.
So you can think about that in
terms of this plot here.
If you have reactants going to
intermediate, and this is fast
and reversible, so they're going
back and forth, fast,
reversible, and very little of
that intermediate is getting
siphoned off, this
is very slow.
So very, very little
of this is being
siphoned off to products.
So that allows that first step
to really reach equilibrium
conditions, because this doesn't
really factor in, and
so you reach an equilibrium
here.
And that allows you to simplify
your expressions.
So now, we can go back with our
simplified expression, and
we can express it as rate
constant k 1 over rate
constant k minus 1 times n o
squared, or we can write it as
the equilibrium constant 1 times
n o squared, and we can
plug that in solving for
our intermediate.
And so, if we put that now back
into this expression, we
have the 2 k 1, k 2, we have our
oxygen concentration and
our n o squared over k minus 1,
or we can have equilibrium
constant 1 with our
k 2 in our 2.
And now, we're consistent.
If we realize that the k
observed that was given in the
experimental rate law is a
combination of all of our k
terms. So it's a combination,
you can't, at least in this
experiment, you weren't able to
come up with the individual
rate constants, they just came
up with overall observed rate,
and so that's all of
our terms in there.
And so if we put that in here,
we realize that this is
consistent with the
experiment.
And in doing these problems,
it's OK to leave your little
rate constants, it's OK to use
equilibrium constants in
there, you should show all of
your work, so that if you have
a k obs in your final answer, we
can look back and see what
that was equal to.
So it's hard not to show all
your work as you're writing
through all of these on a test,
but you can end your
answer, it would be correct
end your answer
here or here or here.
So I don't care which k is
in your final answer, but
definitely show all your work.
So that agrees with
the experiment.
All right, so let's look
at another example now.
And now we have, again, a 2-step
reaction, and the first
step is fast and reversible, and
the second step is slow.
So, with those predictions of
the mechanism, let's just go
right through and try to solve
for the rate here without
going through all of the steps
we did the first time and see
if we can do this more
efficiently.
And again, this is a reaction
with ozone, and depletion of
ozone is a major problem that
will be facing us, that has
faced us, and will continue
to face us in the future.
All right.
So lets first think about the
rates of the individual steps.
So the rate of the forward
reaction here
is going to be what?
Just yell it out.
Yup, k 1 times the concentration
of o 3.
What about for the
reverse step?
Yup, it's like clear and then
it gets mumbly. k minus 1
times the concentration of o 2
times this concentration of o,
which is an intermediate.
All right, so let's look at
the second step here.
So the rate here is going to be
k 2 times this intermediate
-- concentration of this
intermediate, o times the
concentration of o 3.
All right, so now we know that
this second step is going to
be controlling the rate, it's
a slow step, at least that's
our prediction that we're
going to write a rate
expression based on.
And so, that's going to be
our slow step, our rate
determining step.
And again, we're forming two
molecules of o 2 in this step.
So we can have a two in there.
And that the rate of formation
of o 2 in this last step, 2
times k 2 times our intermediate
o times o 3.
Are we done?
Was it that easy?
No.
Why isn't this finished?
There's an intermediate.
Intermediates will not be your
friend in doing these
problems.
Yes, we have an intermediate
so we're not complete.
We need to solve for o in terms
of products, reactants,
and rate constants.
So we're not done.
So we need to get rid
of the intermediate.
But now, we can do that more
simply because we've set this
up that we have a fast
reversible step
followed by a slow step.
So we can solve for the
concentration of that
intermediate in terms of
equilibrium expressions.
So, if you haven't learned how
to write an equilibrium
expression yet, remember you
need it for the unit on
chemical equilibrium, the unit
of acid base, the unit of
oxidation reduction, and here
you need it again in kinetics,
so definitely want to be able to
write those for the final.
So we can go ahead
and write those.
So, for the first step, again,
it's products over reactants.
You can also express that in
terms of rate constant k 1
over rate constant k minus 1,
and that's all equal to our
big k, our equilibrium
constant, k 1.
And so now we can solve in terms
of o, our intermediate,
and so here, we pull that out,
here we've solved for it in
terms of k 1 times o 3 over k
minus 1 times o 2, so we just
brought those to
the other side.
You could have also used the
equilibrium constant here
instead of the rate constants,
either one is OK.
So, now we've solved for it
here, and we can put it down
into this expression here.
So we are going back
to our overall
expression that we wrote.
So the expression that we wrote
based on this was 2, k 2
times the concentration of our
intermediate, times the
concentration of o 3.
Now we substitute in for the
intermediate, so we have 2
times k 2, k 1, we have o 3 and
an o 3, so that squared,
over k minus 1 times o 2.
And this can also be expressed
in terms of k observed,
putting those terms together,
o 3 squared over o 2.
And that would be the answer to
what the rate is for that
particular proposed mechanism.
So, let's think about if that's
true, what we should
expect if we do some
experiments, what we should
expect about the order of the
reactions, and what would
happen if you double
concentrations of things and
look for the effect.
So if you're going to
test this proposal,
what would we get?
So, what is the overall order
of this rate law here.
Oh, sorry, the order first
let's do of o 3.
2.
So if we double the
concentration of o 3, what
would you expect to see
in terms of the rate?
It will what?
Yup, quadruple.
What is the overall order of o
2, or order of o 2, and that
is a clicker question,
actually.
So you know what some
people think.
And not only tell me the order,
but tell me the effect
of doubling.
OK, let's just take
10 more seconds.
Very good.
All right, so the overall minus
1, that's what it means
if it's on the bottom of
that equation there.
And so if we double it
then it should half.
So overall then, what is the
order of the reaction?
It's 1.
And so, remember you can sum up
the order of the individual
ones to get the overall order,
so the overall order is 1.
And what about if you double
both things, what's going to
happen to the rate?
OK, let's just take
10 more seconds.
OK, people are doing
quite well on this.
All right, so you double
both and you double.
So, everyone's in very good
shape on these types of
problems, which is excellent
because this is worth
a lot on the final.
All right, so let's do a final
example, and in this case
we're given an experimental rate
law, which is up here, k
observed times the concentration
of n o and the
concentration of b r 2, and we
want to figure out from this,
we'll look at if we have one
step is being fast and the
other step is being fast, and
see which would be consistent
with this experimentally
determined rate law.
So these are some of the types
of problems you have, your
given experimental rate law and
say tell me which step has
to be fast and which has to be
slow to have a rate that's
consistent with the
observed rate.
So, in this reaction we
have 2 n o plus b r 2
going 2 n o b r.
So if we write this in the first
step, we have n o plus b
r 2 going to an intermediate,
n o b r 2 with forward rate
constant, k 1, and reverse
rate constant, k minus 1.
And in the second step we have
the intermediate interacting
with another molecule of n o
forming two molecules of n o b
r, our product.
So let's consider what the rate
of the forward reaction
is here, and so that would be
-- you can yell it out. k 1
times -- yes, excellent.
And for the reverse reaction
then we're going to have our k
minus 1 times our intermediate
concentration.
Now we can look at step 2 where
our intermediate is
being consumed, and the rate
would equal then k 2 times the
concentration of the
intermediate, n o b r 2 times
the concentration of n o.
All right, so we know nothing
now about fast or slow steps,
so we can write the formation
of our product just in terms
of this second step.
And again, there are two
molecules being formed, so we
have a 2, and 2 times this rate
for this second step, k 2
times intermediate times n o.
So again, now we have an
intermediate that we have to
get rid of.
We can't have an intermediate
in our final expression.
But we can't use the equilibrium
constant right now
because we don't know anything
about what are the fast or the
slow steps.
So we're going to write it the
long way with no assumption
about fast or slow steps.
So to do this, so we have our
intermediate, and so we're
going to solve for it in terms
of products and reactants.
So we're going to write about
the change in the
concentration of that
intermediate.
So, the intermediate's being
formed in the first step.
So we first write the rate at
which it's being formed.
So it's being formed here, so
that's k 1 times n o times the
concentration of b r 2, so this
is how it's being formed.
And then we're going to consider
how it's being
decomposed, and you told me
before it gets decomposed in
the reverse of the first step.
So we have a minus sign, because
this is a negative
change in concentration, it's
being decomposed, and it's
being decomposed with a rate
constant of k minus 1 times
the concentration of
that intermediate.
And the intermediate's also
being consumed, so that's
decreasing the concentration of
the intermediate, and it's
being consumed in this
second step.
So it's being consumed here with
the rate constant of k 2
times the intermediate
times n o.
So that second step.
So this is how we write it if
we don't know anything about
the rate at which -- what's slow
and what's fast. So this
will always, always work to
write things this way.
So that's the overall change
in the concentration of the
intermediate, how it's
being formed,
decomposed, and consumed.
Now we can use the steady state
approximation, and you
can always use the steady state
approximation in these
problems, and that says that
this net change is going to be
equal to zero.
So the steady state
approximation, then, let's you
set this entire term
equal to zero.
And sometimes, a question you
might get is to say what the
steady state approximation is.
So you should be able to
articulate that in words as
well as use it on a problem.
So now we can set this all
equal to zero, and we can
solve for our concentration
of our intermediate.
So, rearranging this then,
bringing our intermediate
terms on one side of the
expression, and again, here's
the rate at which it's
decomposed and consumed being
equal to the rate at which
it's being formed.
And we can pull out our
intermediate, so then that's
times k minus 1, k 2 times n
o, and that's equal to the
rate at which it's
being formed.
And so now we can take that,
divide by that term, and we
get an expression for the
concentration of the
intermediate in terms
of our reactants
and our rate constants.
So now we need to plug that
back in to the original
equation that we had.
So this is what we solved for,
and now we can put it into
here, and if you rearrange that,
we have the 2, we have
the k 1, we have the k 2, we
have an n o here, we have an n
o there, so it's squared, b r 2
here, and then on the bottom
we have k minus 1 plus
k 2 times n o.
OK, so that's great, but that's
not consistent with the
experimentally determined rate
law, so something has to be
fast and something
has to be slow.
So let's first consider if the
first step is slow and the
second step is fast, which would
mean that the second
step is bigger, it's faster,
that's k 2 times n o would be
bigger than k minus 1.
So the second step then is
fast, faster than this.
So now why don't you go ahead
and tell me how this
simplifies if that is true.
All right, let's just take
10 more seconds.
Yup.
All right, let's look at why.
All right, so that's the answer
and let's consider why.
So that means if this is much
bigger than this term, that
cancels out.
If that cancels out, what else
cancels? k 2 also cancels, and
what else cancels? one n o
cancels giving you this
expression.
And that is consistent with
the answer up there.
So you could also see that
as the k observed.
So that's consistent.
And let's just quick
-- oh, first tell
me the overall order.
2.
And now let's just look at what
would have been true if
we had done it the
other way around.
So if we did it the other way
around, we'd say that the
first step is fast so that's
a lot bigger than this.
If this is a lot bigger than
that, we'd cancel out this
second term here.
Can anything else cancel?
No.
So, we're left with this
expression, and that is not
consistent with this up
here, because we have
this squared term.
So even if you write it as
k observed, that's not
consistent.
And so, the overall order for
this would have been 3, which
is not consistent with
the experiment.
All right, so now you know
everything you need to know to
finish problem-set 10.
Don't let anything be your
rate determining step.